hey everyone meet kevin here welcome
back to another episode of the meet
kevin
show today we have the host of the david
pakman show
and i want to bring this up up front we
had a lauren southern on
a few weeks ago and a lot of folks were
wondering hey we want to get somebody
with
the opposite perspective and i thought
hey
i think that might be david who's got a
channel on youtube he's the host of the
david pakman show
he's got some really great insights and
so david welcome board introduce
yourself thank you it's so great to be
here i appreciate it
thank you so much so i want to get
started i want to jump right into this
we got 45 minutes to drill you in your
thoughts here on
on politics stimulus infrastructure why
don't we start with stimulus
what have you seen out there with a
stimulus do you think this is actually
helping is this stimulating our economy
you know did it uh should trump have
done more is biden doing enough tell me
a little bit
where where's your head i mean listen my
approach to this
is from my background in economics the
politics i mean
you know it i make no secret about the
fact that i'm on the left but
this is pretty much basic macro
economics
we had a demand collapse when the
pandemic happened
uh people stopped demanding at uh at a
macro economic level
a bunch of different goods and services
that were previously
uh steadily demanded and the way you
in the in the short to medium term deal
with uh collapse in demand
is you stimulate demand by giving people
money money to spend
and there are all sorts of
considerations about the long term and
people
want to and we can talk about things
like inflation spirals and all of these
different things
but in in the sort of medium term um
this made made sense and it worked to
some degree
um we still had unemployment increase i
think the way to avoid that would have
been
to pay businesses to keep people
on payrolls even if their businesses
weren't fully functioning that's not the
way they chose to do it
um and so you know two of these packages
were done by trump one was done by biden
they were similar in many ways
i don't have a dramatically different
political analysis for for two versus
the third
i think they all could have been done
and should have been done more quickly
though
i got you so the the roadblocks like
that we saw with the heroes act for
example back like
that last may that was passed by
democrats do you think something like
that that
large package should have been passed a
lot sooner than so so you're
kind of a proponent of the keynesian
kind of school of thought where let's
spend when the market's down
it's not about about keynesian it's if
we were going to spend it we could have
done much more good for the american
people by not delaying
for political reasons and this applies
to joe biden as well you know joe biden
said we're going to do it right away
and it's going to be two thousand
dollars and it was 1400 more
and it took several months and you know
it got done that's that's what matters
um and and that's that's great but i
think all of these things
could have been done more quickly is
that just a
symptom of our congress though i mean
does that sometimes i've had this theory
before that
uh because our congress is so
dysfunctional things take so long in
a definition of dysfunctional everything
just takes way longer than expected
is it possible that that actually in a
weird way keeps inflation
lower because people expect like oh
government's spending more money
yeah okay that's going to take forever
to get through good luck you know is
that possibly something that actually
keeps inflation down or are we going to
spiral not sure i understand you're
saying uh the stimulus
being delayed lowered inflation yeah
so in in a weird and this is a weird
theory i have the theory i have is
the more dysfunctional our congress is
and the longer things take to get
the lev the lower people's expectations
for inflation are
which could mean lower inflation in the
future because we think
even though the government has spent a
lot and they might spend a lot more
they're so slow at doing it imagine this
for a moment just to go to the extreme
imagine they could come up with a
stimulus bill and a napkin
and pass it in 24 hours and then they're
like all right let's do 1.9 today
okay a month goes by let's do another
one nine you know i feel like all of a
sudden people's trust in the currency
would evaporate and we'd see inflation
hyperinflation right away
we kind of have this opposite extreme
where it's a disaster to get things
passed
yeah uh i mean no i don't so there's a
lot of ifs ands and buts there but
i think the most important thing to
understand is the fear-mongering around
hyperinflation when the government does
stuff has been with us for decades
but inflation has remained very low we
were told
that there was going to be
hyperinflation when barack obama in 2009
did tarp and we didn't have it
and we were told we were going to get
super inflation when trump did the first
stimulus and it never happened
and when he did the second stimulus and
it never happened and what were
now as we become more sophisticated in
our economic understanding
we understand things like modern
monetary theory and we realize that
if the government were to the term
printing money is not even relevant
because it's really computers at this
point but
if the government were to put money
digitally
in the bank's accounts to pay down
foreign debt that could have an
inflationary effect that's not what's
been done
the money has been
doled out to stimulate demand
and it goes into small business it goes
into production
it's gdp positive and when you do that
you don't get that inflation that some
people fear monger about and you we
don't need to speculate
just look at inflation over the last 30
years yeah now
what do you say to people who say hey
david
true inflation's been trending down over
the last 30 years but i mean look at
commodity prices now look at copper look
at lumber you know we've we've got
prices of everything's going up except
for maybe apparel
used cars are getting more expensive
isn't this a sign that
that's it hyperinflation is officially
here
uh absolutely not so let's break down
each so you just you gish galloped me
there i don't know if you know that
are you familiar with that term i i
think i have a feeling but i'll let you
explain
you threw a bunch of stuff at me that
seem like
related examples but they're really not
so so let's kind of
give me it was used cars commodity
prices so
i appreciate you doing that because
people gish gallup all the time so i
appreciate that
so let's start with let's start with
lumber is that just a symptom of real
estate prices going up and low rates
so lumber there's a couple things in
general with commodities
over long periods commodity prices go
down
because technology allows us to more
efficiently
manage harvest create whatever
okay so so over the long term short-term
commodity price increases
tend to be blips and they tend to be
based on
sort of a narrow supply and demand um
people wanting to move to suburbs during
coronavirus
get more space for work from home
certainly has driven
uh real estate sectors up you need
lumber to build that so that would be
lumber but over the long term commodity
prices still trend down
used cars is an interesting one because
demand for new cars versus used cars
are sort of different markets and the
reason why we're seeing more demand
for used cars in part is because
of economic circumstances where people
are less able to afford
new cars so you have to understand
sort of the context there and then
apparel we know why apparel has been
getting cheaper and cheaper
for 20 years or longer the u.s has
decided and by decided i mean implicitly
that we prefer to pay less for things
like clothes
by getting them manufactured in
countries with cheaper labor
uh and not to pay higher wages here in
the united states to the people that
would be making those clothes so they're
all different markets and different
explanations
which is one of the reasons i feel like
nike is getting blasted now though for
using cheaper labor although that's kind
of what people want is a cheaper product
huh
yeah i mean listen when we talk about
um let's buy let's manufacture american
and let's buy american and let's bring
everything back
we could do that it took decades to get
our supply chains to what they are now
so it would take a long time
but it would come with higher prices
it's not necessarily bad
we would pay more for nike shoes and
workers in the u.s making shoes would
make more money
it would be a decision and what our
elected officials decided over the last
30 years is
we'd rather the cheaper stuff and we'd
rather offshore the jobs
right right now do you think that uh
this well i want to
touch on the cars thing really quick is
is that sort of like the example of uh
of griffin goods where where you kind of
get these uh uh
as as sort of incomes uh well i guess
i'm trying to think of what that would
be an example of i can't think of the
economic term right now
but people are it's basically people are
substituting is what you're saying
people are substituting the used cars
for the newer cars but don't you think
that stimulus is changing that i mean
now people are getting their stimulus
checks
and they're not enough for example for
pickup trucks on the lots anymore
and so we're seeing the price of new
cars also going up
yeah i'm unsure about um people making
car buying decisions
with 1400 bucks it doesn't it doesn't
sound intuitive to me that that's what
would be happening i i think the
argument is a family of four might be
getting that 5600 bucks
so maybe that might be enough for a down
payment yeah it's conceivable um you
know i
i uh i think that if you are if you're
depending on
stimulus to get a car you probably
shouldn't be looking at a new car but
that's more of a personal finance
perspective than an economic one good
point okay so
you're thinking a lot of these prices
that are going up
are short-term supply chain maybe
inefficiencies or blips or problems
which
is not going to translate into inflation
a lot of folks believe
that the cpi data is rigged that
basically anytime there's a hint that
inflation is going up they change the
formula
or whatever what's your take on this how
do you respond to folks saying you can't
trust the cpi just look around prices
are going up
yeah um there's no question that there's
an arbitrary nature to cpi
what is the basket of goods that you
include in cpi and there's no doubt
that bad faith has could manipulate
what's included and what's excluded in
order to generate a particular result
but there's lots of other independent
measures you can
google alternative to cpi for measuring
inflation
and none of them point to significant
inflation
nice so uh i mean not seeing
hyperinflation is is a good thing
because i think if we saw hyperinflation
it would be pretty bad
uh for for a lot of us in society uh
what's your long-term view do you
believe that the federal reserve is
uh is going to raise rates sooner a lot
of folks on wall street right now say
look we got a price in higher inflation
it's coming the fed's going to be wrong
they won't have the luxury of waiting
until 2023
24 they're gonna have to move in 22. i
uh
i don't see much um good
in predicting what the fed will do much
the same way that
you know i think that most economic
predictions are basically guesses and
and humans are notoriously bad at making
financial predictions
so i have no idea i i believe the fed
when it says
its belief in its intention is that uh
they're going to keep late rates low for
the foreseeable future
um i think if circumstances change they
would probably revisit
but beyond that you know there's no
particular prediction i would make
gotcha do you think that the stimulus
has created
distortions keeping companies alive that
shouldn't be alive
should we have just let a bunch of
companies go bankrupt and go under
because
maybe now certain companies that that
are here today shouldn't be around and
they're just absorbing capital from from
other folks
sure so i think the the question of
stimulus for business has to be divided
into
big business and then local and small
businesses
uh local and small businesses
very often nature are very low profit
margin businesses
and i know for example restaurant owners
who
basically lose money eight months of the
year a little bit right
but then four months of the year they
make the bulk of their profit
and so if those four months aren't good
they're no longer a viable business so
that's an example where
these are the small businesses bars
cafes local bookstores that are really
kind of like the fabric of neighborhoods
and i don't think we are sort of bailing
out bad businesses when we give them a
bridge during the pandemic
i think the bigger question is about
big business and whether they should be
subsidized to the tune of
sometimes billions of dollars and the
answer is it depends on the industry
and it depends on the business you know
take something like airlines
i can see both sides on airlines on the
one hand these are already heavily
subsidized businesses
why are we giving them even more money
at this point in time
on on the other hand airlines are
infrastructure
and airports are how people come and do
business with the united states so you
can make the case that
for the long-term good of the economy
you need to help those businesses out i
think i think there's a debate to be had
there
gotcha yeah that's something where you
get a lot of i hear uh
kevin o'leary made this argument that
screw the airlines
let the airlines go bankrupt bail out
the workers directly and not the
airlines is is that
a similar to what you're describing well
no
in the sense that if you let the airline
fail and then you give the workers money
until they find another job
great that's essentially unemployment
insurance and that's fine
the question is when travel resumes
if it's more of a pain to fly to the u.s
because american has gone out of
business for example
you're going to incentivize others to do
business elsewhere rather than here so
it's a
really it's it's fundamentally an
infrastructure question and
uh airlines are part of infrastructure
the way the the grid is the way
internet increasingly is so i i i don't
i i'm not exactly on board with the way
kevin o'leary would describe it
how do you feel about the expanding of
let's say broadband to rural areas and
and the big spending that
biden is proposing in his infrastructure
plan
is is this uh really going to stimulate
our economy or is this really just
fixing stuff that should have been fixed
and
should the package be a lot smaller well
both of the things you mentioned are
good
spending that stimulates the economy is
good fixing things that should be fixed
is good
the fact that they should have been
fixed before isn't a good reason not to
fix them now
so it's it's a bunch of different things
um
i i think that one of the interesting
things in watching some on the right
oppose this bill
uh have been that this type of
infrastructure spending number one most
of the work is done by private industry
so there's a lot of people who say i
don't want the government doing so much
stuff well it's really going to be
private businesses getting hired by the
government to do it and and private
business
is something the right claims to support
and and
and favor the other interesting thing is
that from the standpoint of a business
infrastructure spending is cost
externalization and what i mean by that
is if you're a store
you depend on the roads being passable
you depend on street lights working you
depend on
infrastructure like electrical and
plumbing and all these things to work
right you're able to have customers
easily be able to come and give you
money
thanks to the infrastructure spending of
the government so you would think that
the right would love it it's a way for
businesses to
reap profits thanks to someone else's
infrastructure spending
wow yeah that completely makes sense now
the
right argument the republican argument
right now seems to be well let's do a
six to seven hundred billion dollar
package let's do that let's let's do the
infrastructure
but uh republicans are obviously heavily
opposed to
uh green and uh climate initiatives
energy efficiency standards you know
donald trump one of the big things he
did was
remove energy efficiency requirements or
at least some of them
for vehicles to say hey well if we lower
prices people can afford a new car and
that'll increase average fuel
efficiency what's your stand on that
well listen for whatever reason
republicans seem extremely intimidated
by large packages they have a tendency
for small sometimes very weak packages
with terrible performance if you
understand what i'm saying
reading between the lines here right
yeah so um i
i think that the games around
fine-tuning package
size are less interesting to me than
fundamentally
what one's philosophical approach to the
role of government should be
because really it's not that if the
package is a little tinier
or it's a little flimsier republicans
all of a sudden
love it it's they don't believe
fundamentally
that the government should be even
involved in this
many of them because they are such
extreme small government conservatives
so it's not even you know
package size they they try to flaunt
tiny packages i don't know what they're
bragging about quite frankly
but i i i don't even think they're
talking in good faith quite frankly
gotcha yeah got it so it's it's really
more of just a contrasting argument like
there's there's not a small package to
be had that would
function as well as this it's just we
don't want you know two two let's how
about 600
that's exactly right that the small
package is not going to work that well i
think you understand what i'm saying
nobody likes small packages right we
gotta have big packages in america
so uh i mean this is gonna be huge
though because we're thinking about
up to four trillion dollars uh 2.2 and
then the next phase the social
infrastructure package
of of one nine uh what's your stance on
that you know is it
should i mean is this a step towards
universal basic income for example the
child tax credit to say hey let's uh
let's give people 250 to 300 a month uh
to
have child poverty uh but uh now is this
a step towards a universal basic income
it may be you know the what the reason
that i think it's not
is that there's there's you know right
now democrats control
everything white house house and senate
yeah even many democrats in the senate
don't support
universal basic income so i know that
there are some on the right who think
that the child tax credit is some kind
of
stealth way to uh get
get universal basic income i mean that
sounds interesting i think
universal basic income is interesting i
also think a negative
income tax rate at certain income levels
would be an alternative
i don't think it's the precursor to ubi
gotcha
what's your thought on the linkage
between
poverty and crime we hear stats that
maybe if you're in poverty you're two
and a half times more likely to be
a victim of violent crime is there a
link between being poor
and a direct increase in crime so you'd
i want to make sure i understand the
question you said that being poor makes
you more likely to be the victim of
crime you're not talking about a
perpetrator
yes i think that's undeniably true i
mean crime is higher in poor
neighborhoods
so it i think that that's absolutely
both intuitive and borne out by by the
facts yeah
yeah it and so if uh the child tax
credit or a form of universal basic
income could eliminate poverty
should the country have universal basic
income to eliminate poverty and
and maybe take people out of those
situations yeah again i i've uh i
started interviewing andrew yang
years ago and he was one of the earlier
more notable people talking about ubi
and many other folks i generally tend to
like
ubi as an idea now the the devil is in
the details some folks want to do ubi
to replace all welfare programs right
and just
give everybody ubi you reduce
bureaucratic and administrative costs
it's demand side stimulus great
you're kind of done with it others have
the idea of every ubi dollar
comes out of some other program you also
have to look at how the federal poverty
line is set
there's a lot to this but generally
speaking i
the the ubi pilot programs have
gone really well in terms of reducing
stress and anxiety around having food
for your family
and they've been economically
stimulative so i think it's a great idea
to pursue
now i want to ask you the the reverse of
what you picked up on
uh and that is do you think that being
in poverty could lead
to crime that is lead somebody to commit
crime because
maybe they have no alternative yeah i
think again intuitively it makes sense
that
if you are in a desperate situation
where you uh need to
figure out a way to feed yourself to
feed your family etc
you are going to be more likely to be
willing to do things that somebody who
is not in a desperate situation is is uh
going to be willing to do so it makes
absolute intuitive sense
what do you think about the uh housing
crisis
uh an affordability crisis that we're
seeing is this uh
is this a symptom of the the uh
quote unquote money printing because we
know it's not actual printing like you
had said
uh that's going on these artificially
low rates or are they artificially low
should we be at zero percent forever and
uh is this a problem for people to be
able to build their wealth not being
able to get into real estate
yeah so there's a couple different
things going on one is the issue of
rates rates tend to move inverse to
prices as obvious as of course you know
um and then there's also the issue of
cost of living relative to wages because
in in principle it wouldn't be bad for
housing prices to continue to go up if
wages are keeping track with that but
the problem is that they've become
sort of disaggregated you end up with
people having to live further and
further from their job in order to
to be able to afford a home so much like
with
the cost of college i think that
affordability is a major problem during
the pandemic interestingly enough
in many cities and you may you may know
more about this than i do in many cities
the sort of
mid-tier to luxury market has done
really well
whereas lower markets have not done
quite so well when it comes to
real estate prices and so i think that
to have the conversation more precisely
it's good to kind of segment into
different different markets
uh but there's no question that you look
at some cities and you look at the
state's
minimum wage and the median wage and the
cost to live in a city it's completely
out of whack
and it's similar to college in this
sense you look at the cost of a degree
relative to what you would expect to
earn with that degree and it's gotten
increasingly out of whack in the same
way
in that case is there an argument to say
that maybe
maybe college isn't for everyone maybe
housing isn't for everyone maybe the
american dream isn't
college degree in housing maybe it's uh
it's different
is there an argument to be had that hey
sled housing prices go up and just let
the rich buy it
yeah i i don't think that so i think the
college one is more interesting to me
let's go back to that one with housing i
mean what's the alt
if you don't have housing you're on
you're homeless right so i mean i don't
know so you're renting yeah well but the
the cost of rent will be based on what
the landlord
paid to buy the house so we're really
talking about all all the same thing in
a sense
so that one i don't know that we can say
let's not worry about it
i i do think that increasingly
you're going to see uh for example
people around my age
when my hypothetical kids are
going to college i think you're going to
see two things
if college prices aren't gotten under
control and maybe they will be you know
20 years from now
one is you're going to see more and more
people um
skip college altogether and go directly
into entrepreneurship
and unfortunately it sounds like maybe
that's good but the problem is that
entrepreneurship
is very cronyistic and nepotistic
so the the haves are going to say that
to their kids
don't spend you know 280 000 on a
four-year degree
come intern with me i'll introduce you
to people and they're going to do fine
but it's going to further
create inequality um i think you you
also
may see more jobs say we're not going to
require a college degree increasingly
requiring a college degree
has been something done to reduce the
number of applicants and to create
some kind of uh triage in a sense or
some initial screening
but you may increasingly see some
employers say we're not going to require
a college degree we're going to go about
this a different way
how do you think government should
intervene here do you think it's
government's responsibility to uh
intervene with with either housing or
college or just let people decide in
that case i mean
and even another thing and i've thrown a
few things at you but even another thing
is
like you mentioned we know um that
entrepreneurship
has a high failure rate you know maybe
because of some of the things that
you've described
right i i don't know the answer to the
full
scope that government should have i
think that at this point if we were
rebuilding if we were re
going back to day one i think my answer
would be different given where we are
today
uh number one with so many predatory
uh student loans out there i would like
to see some student loan forgiveness now
some in my audience
don't like that i don't think it should
be blanket forgiveness for everybody
regardless of economic
circumstances or current job or field or
whatever
but i would like to see some level of
student loan forgiveness
the problem is that you continue to see
an escalation
because it's so easy to get student
loans
that colleges have no incentive to keep
prices lower and then as prices go up
people can just get a loan and it's
become disaggregated this attack
it's unattached from what you would
expect to earn
i don't actually know how to break the
cycle
that makes sense now uh do you believe
that
uh oh going back to sort of housing and
renting here
that uh joe biden's administration
yesterday i believe announced uh
that the consumer financial protection
bureau was considering letting people in
mortgage forbearance
apply for a loan modification that would
let them extend their loan
up to 40 years as long as their payment
obviously would go down in that case
and that there would be no foreclosure
through some point in 2020
do you believe that at some point maybe
is the government just doing too much
for homeowners uh and and
uh artificially reducing the inventory
that we should be seeing in the market
it's theoretically possible that they
could do that now i didn't i didn't see
this proposal to
so that i understand it's not extend a
mortgage by 40 years but
to 40 years right it says extend up to
40 years i
i imagine i actually have the document
here uh so i'll pull it up here really
quick because then we can look at it
together
uh it's a pretty incredible piece it
hasn't received a lot of coverage
uh yet so take a peek at it here a
servicer would be allowed to offer and i
know it says allow to offer i'll explain
this like the loan uh the criteria would
include the loan
modification would extend the term of
the loan by no more than 48 months
so in some sense it kind of implies it
could be an additional 480 months right
and then down here loan modification
must be made available to those
experiencing a coven 19 hardship
yeah i mean so let's see with something
like a car loan
this trend to longer and longer loans on
a depreciating asset
seems nuts to me and what i regularly
say is
if you need a 72 or an 84-month loan for
this car
this isn't the car for you that's my
approach on personal because it's a
depreciating asset
right homes in principle particularly
over the long term
are not depreciating assets obviously
you have bubbles that pop and you have
areas that that may be different so i
have no problem
with um delaying or canceling
foreclosures due to hardship that seems
to make perfect sense
also foreclosure isn't isn't great for
anybody in the sense that banks
also don't love the idea of foreclosing
and then having to sell
the property it's it's not good for any
foreclosed upon your ability to continue
working and earning income and all these
things
is mitigated so i think that there's
there's value dollar value in preventing
a foreclosure
by how much you allow loan extension
it's above my
pay grade it would be for someone else
to decide adding 40 years to a 30-year
mortgage
seems questionable to me but i'm only
going by
you know this is the first i've heard of
this proposal sure i'll send it to you
yeah we'll talk about it after uh so
what about um
i'm going to ask you this one a little
bit of a pivot here is trump coming back
i have no idea i think it'll it'll it'll
depend on the fault i think there's a
couple things going on
one i think by 2024 trump will be bored
moving on to something else or maybe in
in poor health
so wow i don't know that it's it's that
likely just knowing
trump but i think what it'll really
depend on is whether trump can play king
maker successfully in 2022 there's these
members of congress
uh some of them are a little cuckoo for
coco puffs um madison taylor green
and lauren beaubert madison cawthorne
who don't really have policy
they ran on we like trump and trump
supported them and they won
now if they get re-elected in 2022
with trump's fundraising with trump's
help that gives
trump power uh it gives him
hand right to to take a quote from
seinfeld
and he can probably better justify
running in 2024.
if these trumpian clowns go down
in in flames in 2022 it makes it hard
for trump to justify running in 2024 but
for the time being
the party is still the party of trump
most republicans support trump
most want him to run and if that
continues he he may well give it another
shot
wow wow do you think he'll win no idea
no i mean just it's it's sure maybe i
mean it's
at this this we have it'll depend on
what happens in the six months prior to
the 2024 election and we just don't know
what that's going to be yet
now i like your economics background and
i want to go back to that uh but
also including the politics here why is
it every day
when i pop over to fox business fox
business not fox fox business
uh you know when i balance between
bloomberg and cnbc
they're talking about the border wall
and and the border crisis what
connection
to business are they making here you'd
have to ask them i don't know
i mean i think um i guess they would you
know one of the things they talk about
is about brown immigrants stealing jobs
from americans that's a narrative so i
guess that's sort of a business thing
but you know the real business story
with undocumented immigration
is that the businesses hiring the
undocumented immigrants don't get in
trouble i mean if you
if you want to stop so-called
immigration
stealing american jobs punish the
businesses doing the hiring which
happens so rarely
that's interesting whether that's the
farms or
uh clothing manufacturers in los angeles
or whatever
why chase essentially down the the
worker when it's when it's really the
businesses that are providing these
but but doesn't that go back to the case
of sanctuary cities uh like los angeles
who enable this uh no these are these
are
sort of uh these are different things
and uh i i don't
i don't fully see the connection also
the the vast majority of these
um large employers of
huge groups of undocumented immigrants
are not in cities anyway
where where are you finding them uh
agricultural areas
um a lot of meat packing plants and you
have things that are based in
very small cities or rural areas
that makes sense now uh what do you
think about
uh you know there are a lot of folks
fleeing for example parts of south
america
or or not necessarily directly our
immediate border but other parts of
south america because of hyperinflation
that's happened in their country and a
lot of them are trying to
come to the country with with bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies
where's your sort of mindset on these
inflationary dynamics in less stable
regimes or countries uh and uh and and
people's uh
fascination with cryptocurrency and
inflation so a few different things
there
one is when we talk about dealing with
immigration
the arguably the the most under
discussed aspect of this
is if you really want to deal with
immigration at the top
level not like what's the cutoff at
which you send someone that
back versus here or that right that's
micro the macro
is deal with why people are trying to
come here in the first place which are
economic and
political circumstances in their country
so one thing i would really like to see
done in a serious way is for an american
administration
um to actually work with the source
countries for where undocumented
immigrants are coming from
and improve the situation there there's
this false notion
that some have that everybody wants to
come to the united states
really very few people want to come to
the united states from the vast majority
of the world
the people that want to come to the
united states for the most part other
than people
who are highly specialized in fields
that that you know
the elite in that field is here right
very high high skill
folks for the most part the the primary
reason
people want to come here when they do is
because circumstances in their country
are not good and so dealing with that is
one of the best things we can do if we
really want to curb undocumented
immigration
now as far as crypto um i am
maybe different from some on the
political left
in that i like crypto i've been in
bitcoin
for five years at this point
i don't tell anyone what to do with
their money but to me
three to five percent of assets uh in
crypto
seems to make sense to me um for me it's
kind of because it's been
doing so well it's grown to be more than
that but then i sell out of it and i
kind of get into uh other other assets
to maintain
around that three to five percent uh so
so for me
you know i'm i'm kind of tired of the
lame arguments about
uh used to buy drugs or you know this
this type of thing
i think it's a it's a potentially great
thing and
as far as you know immigrants i i don't
i don't
have too much specifically out about
immigrants in crypto
gotcha yeah janet yellen seems to be
perpetuating that narrative uh that
cryptocurrencies are used for illicit
activities is she just a little behind
on our research
yeah i mean so is the u.s dollar right
there's a reason what what percentage of
u.s dollars have traces of cocaine on
them or
whatever the thing is yeah i don't think
that these are bad folks and you've seen
i mean listen look at
look at what jp morgan was saying about
about bitcoin five years ago versus
today
where all you know and it's not just jp
morgan there's this long list of
companies and individuals who were
saying
this is going to zero who now say
even institutions may want to hold one
to two percent in in bitcoin so
it's just it's taken some time but a lot
of people are coming around to it
what are those other assets that you're
moving into when you sell your bitcoin
since you've had it so long and it's run
up
absolute lowest lowest cost uh index
funds
wow okay uh any particular like uh some
of the vanguards or what are you picking
just the widest possible i don't want to
be you know i own some individual stocks
and i've talked about that i'm not
saying anything breaking any new ground
here or saying anything new this is sort
of like the jack bogle
uh uh benjamin graham approach
which is i don't think i'm particularly
good at picking individual stocks so i
have about 10 or 12 individual stocks
that are like
8 to 10 percent of my portfolio but
time time in the market is the most
important thing
than timing or picking stocks and you
know over time because i've had
a mutual fund account now for 15 years
the dividends that i'm now accumulating
just from letting that sit are now
significant they're now actually a
significant portion of my my annual
spend
so that's that's i don't try to do
anything special my big thing is running
my business not picking stocks
so just low low cost index funds
do you think they should lower the uh
income tax rate to help encourage people
like you to keep running your business
uh and how it wouldn't it wouldn't help
me it wouldn't encourage me
i mean uh think about it this way
i don't know why more people don't think
about this
let's try this experiment out on you if
i offered you
a 20 return or a 40 return
which would you pick well of course the
40
right and if i offered you a way to
avoid
a 40 tax or a way to avoid
a 20 tax which tax are you more
interested in avoiding
i want to avoid the 40 tax that sounds
like california
right now you know that all business
expenses are tax deductible right
yup so if taxes are 40
when you invest in your business you
save 40
when taxes are 20 and you invest in your
business
you save only 20 a higher tax
within reason right sure is is more of
an incentive to invest now i'm oh i
i'm way oversimplifying this but this is
people have this very much backwards
the reality is most businesses are going
to expand because of demand for the
product or service that they're offering
and that has less to do with the tax
rate ah that's interesting now some
folks
argue that uh well hey look if if i'm in
california and 55
of my incomes going to the government
they own more of my business than i do
why why am i here what's i mean yeah i
mean you can make the same argument but
you're not going to invest a hundred
percent of your income
either no it nobody is regardless so
this is why i think a lot of these
arguments are too black and white it's
sort of like on minimum wage when some
people say
why fifteen percent dollars if more
money is better what about a hundred
what about a thousand then you have to
say hey hold on a second
a thousand dollars an hour is not a cost
of living adjusted minimum wage
it's not a an equilibrium wage there's
no justification for a thousand dollars
an hour
and you have to slow down some of that
black and white thinking
and um you know i'm right there with you
in that i think uh particularly the
federal
government spends my tax money in
terrible ways i don't want
so much of my tax money going to defense
uh and the military and a lot of this
stuff
um but i i think a more sort of nuanced
understanding of a lot of these taxation
issues is a
a necessity in order to have serious
conversations about it
gotcha now uh one of the big
frustrations in december we could say
was
initiated by donald trump was that 46
billion dollars is being spent on
foreign affairs and that
donald trump said i don't want six
hundred dollar checks i want two
thousand dollar checks and so he stopped
they did not sign that six hundred
dollars to meals check package
uh complaining about this foreign
affairs spending we did a calculation
here that if we took
all of our annual foreign affairs
spendings or 46 billion dollars
and just set that to zero and gave that
to stimulus check increases instead
every person instead of getting 600
would get 776 dollars
one time so an extra 176 dollars but
then we'd have zero foreign fair
spending which means the money we spend
in egypt that helps us
typically use the suez canal minus the
hiccup we had here recently
doesn't happen anymore and those things
happen all around the world uh what's
your take on that i mean is
is really foreign affairs something we
should even consider or is that a small
part of the bucket when we're talking
about
1.9 to 2 trillion dollar stimulus
packages locally
well i think you answer the question
yourself it's 100 and something dollars
per person it's it's it's not
uh it's it's not a huge amount of money
now when you say
you're saying foreign aid right is that
what you mean yes foreign aid
yeah i mean listen foreign aid is
foreign aid is its own topic and
it's it's a it's a big topic and there's
many disagreements about
in what ways shouldn't shouldn't the usb
be spending foreign aid
i think if you simply are making this a
utilitarian
question a lot of that foreign aid
comes back to the united states in the
forms of contracts for american
companies some people call that good
some people call that cronyism you know
you we get we could debate that but i
think that
um foreign aid is complicated because a
lot of that money comes with strings a
lot of that money comes with
countries doing things that are also
good for the united states so it really
depends on your
philosophy about about foreign aid
rather than the dollar amount
on philosophy i want to ask you two
things here and then we're coming to the
end
uh so last year people were able to
apply for
the ppp or mortgage forbearance
essentially by
raising their hand all they had to do
was say please
and here you go 12 months of mortgage
for brands you don't have to make your
payment add it to the back your loan
when you refinance yourself pay it off
uh you raise your hand you want ppp no
problem here you go
is that a problem does that create moral
hazard or
does it matter is it just like hey
everybody raise your hand go get your
free money
whether you need it or not and hey it's
stimulus after all
no it is a problem it is a problem and i
could have i could have taken ppp money
uh eid alone i chose not to i know
people in my field who did
and you know i made a calculation which
was
we had our biggest growth year ever in
2020 because people were stuck at home
watching stuff
and we had an election and it was a
great year and and so i could have taken
the money i made the moral decision
not to take it there's no question that
when donald trump did away with the
oversight
that was supposed to be in place to make
sure it didn't become a slush fund for
cronies and people who didn't really
need it
that it was going to be a fiasco and and
it was so nobody should be surprised
about that
any kind of social insurance program
will have some free riders and some
people who don't really
qualify who will get stuff if the
programs are properly administered
it doesn't really matter because the the
program does way more good than it does
harm
great a few people got away with
something sure you know but if the
oversight is appropriate
we say the overwhelming good overshadows
that
when you eliminate the oversight there's
no question
that exactly what what was predicted is
what happened
and you know steven mnuchin and
everybody else who was involved
they sort of made the con they made the
decision
either explicitly or implicitly by
negligence
to just say we're just going to kind of
look the other way right
right and i mean that certainly
incentivizes people to go i may as well
raise my hand though because everybody
else is doing it and then you find hedge
funds getting the money and
investing it into stocks uh which i want
to leave on that
uh what are you do you even concern
yourself with
evaluations or is it just get my money
invested and forget about it
you're saying in terms of my personal
philosophy yeah
yeah i don't um you know for er every
year
you have people who say look at the p e
ratio
look at the egypt you know all of these
did these different measures of peter
schiller has his own i forget what it's
called k-pop
index yeah the schiller index uh i don't
pay too much attention to it again
because my approach is
when i'm picking individual stocks which
is 10 to 12 i've been public about which
ones they are you know i've been in
tesla since 2015.
netflix since 2015 amazon uh alphabet
uh i bought in march at the dip of the
pandemic i bought live nation thinking
eventually live events are going to come
back i bought zoom yeah it's like
i have 10 or 10 or 12 stocks i'm not
looking at fundamentals
i'm looking at what do i think the
market play is
and then beyond that it's just time in
the market even when stocks go down
dividends remain steady
if dividends are steady but stocks are
cheaper my dividends buy me more
so i am not doing any kind of uh
fundamental analysis like that it's just
the widest
cheapest possible fund and stay in the
market as long as possible
are you selling any of your tesla you
sell bitcoin when it goes up you selling
tesla i i panic sold half
my tesla stock when
the when elon musk tweeted a couple
years ago
i'm talking to the saudis about going
private and the sec said what the hell
are you talking about
420 i thought it was going disastrous so
i sold half of it
obviously it was a mistake uh but it's
fine you know i put the half i sold into
index funds every everything's okay
everything's okay you're fine
yeah that's awesome wow what an amazing
conversation here
anything you want to leave off with and
how should people get in touch with you
uh well listen if you have something if
you want to troll me
don't get in touch with me i have enough
of that to deal with already but
davidpakman.com you know we're on
instagram we're on youtube
but we don't have as many subscribers as
you on youtube but i'm working on it
i'm working on it oh no you guys get
crazy views man
like how many people do you have working
for you we're a team
right now we're a team of three and
we're going to four very soon
very impressive very impressive all
right so david pagmitchell
very nice a great conversation really
really good
uh we'll have to do this again sometime
uh david stand by
thank you everybody for watching if you
found this helpful consider subscribing
sharing the video check out the david
pakman show
and we will see you in the next one